[Music]
what is up guys I'm so excited Risa to
get this seat
I know all right very exciting so you
gonna get up there with me right now
because I have an article and it's like
so dense and information so everyone
good yeah so you guys have been asking
us for ask the field type top ask the
field feels type topics and we got one
of those for you how do we use to do
that was it like hey I'm Joe I'm
whatever I'm gonna yeah and you're
watching two minutes right now jkn meets
a stuff
alright so the question is he's keeping
his hands warm in there okay you're
we're gonna do it Oh bro okay so this
question is do sexual expert does sexual
experience change with age so yes we got
the 20 year olds over here in the 30
year olds over here we're similar in age
you get a similar age and you guys are
similar in age now I'm also I'm closer
to Julia's age yeah that's true I'm only
two years younger than Julia oh boy how
are you 24 like 19 in my soul I always
forget so net how has sex been with you
well I feel like I started late and then
getting the compliment mine do you mind
sharing when you started you lost your
virginity when you're 19 is that
considered late I think for me not
really in it but like all my friends I
lost in high school inside okay I think
it's pretty late for I guess the times
now burns at a 19-2 but depends on how
like you go if it I feel like I went
through it for a battery if you just
want to wait till you're older I think
that's completely fine like it's no like
rush but like I was just too nervous and
like growing up the way I did like
Muslim you're not supposed to talk about
you do it I think that did hinder how it
was coming into sense or like 19 through
like the next few years was like
definitely weird and awkward for me and
then what she's just kind of like
getting that confidence
started like talking to more people and
everything it became better I like you
did the motion thank you because I in a
really strict like you know religious
household yeah but I was too horny I was
like it feels too damn good for it to be
wrong so you did feel guilty
nope okay I said something's wrong with
the church that's what I'm they're
missing out on this good [ __ ] dude I got
a mouth and I can use it for pleasure
and vice versa
Wow cuz I mean I could suck on titties
and [ __ ] that's funnier just imagining
like junior Pastor Joe like having your
own little like sex awkward in junior
high I'm in sixth grade
do you Nicole this is a cult Karima
teach you guys what really happens about
real sex and everything a sex cult
magnet
[Laughter]
I don't know man and then you can note
some Tigers oh no but go back to your
okay okay uh did it has it changed for
you cuz you're you went from 1924 that's
a pretty that's a pretty big jump I feel
like a lot happens I think the maturity
with the girls changed so not the
experience part I mean the whole
experiencing I think from going from a
young age and obviously I was shy but
then when girls get a little more mature
it's more they the way they know I'm
laughing because and the demons very
mature yeah yeah I am a [ __ ] idiot
but like yeah we were saying the girls
were more mature
it's weird cuz it's like obviously like
you there's like there's like I feel
like this to this there's [ __ ] and
then as lovemaking [ __ ] are you
love making love makin but then it's
like that that when the girls get older
I also don't mess with girls my age
cause I feel like I feel like my friends
other guys are ever true
oh the girl the oldest ever two years
older me at that time
oh they all been like two years older
okay but it's like they know more about
what they want and they've had
experience too so it's less than just
like their vocal in their sex you know
and then I am also so it's like like I
asked them what do they like itself do
like you I've given [ __ ] [ __ ] yes
I do
I'm old mature buck oh okay i I mean
[ __ ] when I was 24 I thought lovemaking
was just taking it down a notch and
going slower yeah slow motion
jackhammers yeah like what is porn
you just pow pow pow and in the other
one is like slow motion yeah for me
lovemaking was when the guy was on top
and like anything other than that I'm
like I'll wouldn't [ __ ] mm-hmm yeah
let's not saying like I'll tell you guys
a while ago like how like why don't be
like to watch porn that much because
it's so different cuz I do a ton of porn
just like he's a filmmaker now see all
types of folks but on but like when you
when you go over the same like when you
watch that's the only watching point but
I did it like that's all I knew up to
like 19 didn't even pass that pretty
much but that's how I thought it was
you [ __ ] put her upside down on the
bed and [ __ ] mouth [ __ ]
not exactly port is aggressive dude I
think I knew that kind of [ __ ] is
hardcore yeah that's like the kind of
[ __ ] where you read each others clothes
off but it's like I don't think that's
normal
like on everyday basis like I don't
think people [ __ ] like that on an
everyday basis I've never had sex like
that what [ __ ] are you talking about the
borderline rape porn yeah never like
that that's not real like I don't know
if everybody we're not really in your
world or not real women I guess it
depends on what kind you're saying is
aggressive it like mascara running down
you talking about the [ __ ] choking in
the barfing on the deck ending to the
point where they like die yeah I think
there's content out there that that must
mean that it does happen yeah well yeah
I don't think it's the norm is the thing
most people are into vanilla sex like
what meaning like the basics you know
yeah they're not some cool music and
then what else have anything different
than Anna Dimas experience what do you
mean
like his we're like like 19 it was like
all he knew was a porn style and then
that's he got older then it was like
more mature girls and they knew what
they wanted and then he started
communicating and talking to [ __ ] I
explored very early in life
like I saw private parts and like Show
and Tell kind of [ __ ] and like nobody
tell ya you know like when you're kids
and [ __ ] you're like what do you have
and they're like um like girls let me
fill up their boobies and [ __ ] in
elementary school and all that and like
yeah
no I saw my first root China in second
grade though yeah on a school bus yeah
yeah they were showing it there's like
check it out I hope my daughter but at
that time you're just curious yeah it
wasn't sexual though it was heaven you
might get turned on but you don't know
what the [ __ ] is happening like I would
play for it with like I don't know like
like like my dad would be teaching music
in the living room and then like if
sometimes mothers and daughters will
come in and then the daughters would
like play and we're just hanging out and
I have a 4 going on she's like what's in
there then she comes in like my dick
girl and then for some reason a shirt is
off and I'm filling it up yeah like and
then I remember getting in trouble cuz
one thing led to another and we're like
running around naked in the fort how old
are you you ran in the Whammy will not
run around but we're crawling around
like in the [ __ ] shine field course
in there yeah and then yeah when they
were done they were looking for us we're
like no we were never close on yeah I
was [ __ ] weird or like I would be in
the closet like I would follow my like
my dad would take me to teach piano
somewhere and I'm just playing with the
kids there and then like I remember
being in the closet with one of the
daughters and she was letting me feel
like fill up her boobs yeah and this is
like in elementary so I've been very
sexually that was her she was she was
older oh okay okay she she had boobs or
like yeah she was like she was also kind
of chunky too so that's why she had
boobs anyways like I was elementary
school right and then I was exposed to
like the the physical pleasures early
but I didn't connect it as like this is
sex and then like you know we get into
our friends dad's like playboy stash and
my friend was so funny dude like his tab
I'm part of the park like playboys cuz
he's all like all the articles are so
good
and then dad took bond that bought that
[ __ ] new [ __ ] dude do you guys
remember fighting like I remember my
first time experience with porn was we
found my friend's dad's porn stash in
the closet up somewhere and I feel like
the experience of watching porn for the
first time back then was so weird too
because you're sitting with your friends
yeah next to each other watching naked
people on the TV and yours like I this
is cool guys dude my friends would start
beating off while we're watching that
we've never done that that's weird
yeah what did you do to my friendship on
a whole new level
you know how they taught me how to be
off like I didn't know how to do it
was it instructor no you're like a
Whitford yank out Joe no they're like it
feels good like my friend would jackal I
told the story multiple times but my
friend was jacking off everywhere so
yeah it was a manual tool so funny so
like he would literally you know how in
elementary school we had tables like
this and it was kind of based each other
and it was in blocks of fours yeah so
yeah he sat across from and you saw this
Jack huh no dude so he I would sit here
and he told me that sometimes in class
whoa so as a kid we wore short shorts so
he had his hand this way and he would be
playing with his balls and one time he
sat next to this Cambodian girl and then
he would [ __ ] pull out his dick and
jack off but the way he would jack off
is he would grip his dick and he would
rub his four fingers on the top like
this he wouldn't go like this he grabbed
this and he just goes like this was a
two-handed activity so when both of his
hands disappeared you knew all is going
on so Emmanuel and my other friend Kevin
right like in all the tickets are
[ __ ] Apes so dreaming okay so we were
having like an assembly you know how
like in elementary school you get into
the auditorium and like you line up
right and so our second grade teacher at
the time she [ __ ] I forgot her name but
she was like basically Kevin Emmanuel
were spent
they were basically sitting next to each
other and rubbing the [ __ ] out of their
own dick like with their palm like this
way both of them at the same time like
this right
[Laughter]
like what are you doing right oh you
know which he's doing lady huh these she
didn't stop like that he just kept going
whilst no matter what [ __ ] so we all
look back I was watching over together
there's no rubbing off watching the
typing the teachers are having a [ __ ]
blast it was really a teacher honor to
like talk about this stuff man dude man
how old were you though that was like
second grade like first grade second
grade second first grade but the porno
thing came in maybe third grade liking
the first grade second grade they would
always jackoff and we thought it was so
funny because we didn't know what it was
but then they'll like be like yeah just
hold it and feel it's so good and then
that's when we like discovered porn and
all that stuff and we would like I would
find a combination of like wow looking
at these pictures while touching myself
is dope yeah I remember the first time I
watched porn I discovered porn was like
I think 5th grade and I was on the
internet I never actually saw a magazine
porn and so much later
so the first porn experience was on the
internet and it was milf porn and it was
the most terrifying you didn't have
friends who went to the gas station they
were like oh yeah we chopped jacket cuz
you know I would be in like those black
sleeves yeah all the porn magazines yeah
I never had that Brighton school or like
like going to a friend's house like you
never saw like moving form no there was
pictures oh it was like milf pics and
you look like someone's mom yes Owens
mom and then like their Harry without
clothes and I'm like oh never again
never never ever again
yeah I'm just thinking about what my
childhood was like and so innocent ya
know like it really it really was
because now that I'm thinking about it
like all the elementary I just wasn't
really aware of my own body like I
didn't like in in the sense that like oh
I'm a female and this dude is a male
I didn't see it as an issue like I
remember when I was a kid like I saw my
brother take off his shirt cuz like we
would travel up to Newark a lot cuz my
mom's family is up there and in the van
it gets really hot right and so I was
like telling my moms like hey I want to
take my shirt off too I mean I was like
you know you can't do that I was like
why not Ben does it she can take off his
shirt man she's cool yeah I would let
you yeah and then and then my mom was
like no like you can't do it I was like
why it's like because you're a girl like
so what it's like alright and so like my
mom was like no you can't do it and then
eventually I was able to do it because I
cut me so much yeah well you know you're
such a feminist back then I was like
really sweaty and I just felt like it
wasn't fair and I'm like Ben could do it
why choose that when your mom decide to
fix the AC she like we can't we can't do
this they say it costs money
oh damn Isaiah so we never used it in a
car old cars used more gas more gas
didn't use you guys had a BMW oh my god
my dad my dad told me with that Beemer
that the AC is broken until I moved to
LA and I forgot it worked I was the
first like the whole time I use it I
never learned how to turn it on baby
or maybe he just did because he was like
I [ __ ] hate you and then for me
there's another time in um around that
age where like I would go swimming with
like my mom's friends like sons there's
like three of them and whatnot and it
was just like me and my sister and my
brother we would all hang out with them
and so after we're done swimming we
usually go to shower and rinse off right
so I went into the shower and then one
of the the sons came in yeah I was like
hey you want a shower to God I was like
sure I could I didn't think anything
different of it like we were still
having our swimsuits on and then like
when both my mom and his mom came in
they're like what are you doing you guys
are supposed to take a shower together
and all like your swimsuits no no yeah
yeah we still are so thought you guys
grab together
yeah and when you're rinsing off
together right yeah and then like I
think I think she was about to pull off
the strong stuff oh no that's probably
wasn't gonna go anywhere
it really wasn't good cuz we didn't even
think about him though I don't know what
to me I was especially that she went
somewhere for me that's always when
experimental [ __ ] happens though like
when you get out of a pool
my friend chased me with his [ __ ]
dick he came up to me and he's all like
and I'm all like well [ __ ] you I got a
dick too
and he's all swordfight and he [ __ ]
tried to touch my tip with his tip and I
was like all right [ __ ] team
chia we're making like we were making
like metal yeah we're making like metal
sounds going yeah we were touching and
after I remember one of the favorite
things that we used to like doing was
peeing together like we couldn't wait to
[ __ ] pee like if it's like we're the
bestest of friends and then it's like
all of the guys try to pee at once and
we would save our piece so we could pee
together on the same toilet me and my
brother did that when we were like cross
streams yeah that's how that's our sort
of I mean in terms of dicks though oh
okay that's great about conversations
you when you talk you can relate to each
other
I like when Joe talks because I can't do
anything it's great I want to see all my
childhood friends because they could
relate to me well I guess to conclude
this conversation yeah sex that's
changed
[Music]